now at the end of this presentation your
attention is going to be greatly
improved if you follow what I'm going to
show you there's no doubt that we have a
major problem with attention as well as
the hyperactivity that can be connected
to it so I want to discuss this
condition but just be rest assured there
is a very simple solution that has very
minimal if any side effects and I think
the only problem that people will have
is
how do you come off your medication with
help of your doctor of course and how do
you make that transition well you're
just going to have to do it gradually
with supervision so you could eventually
come off but the diagnosis using the
diagnostic and statistical Manual of
mental disorders which is a little bit
outdated but it's almost the same as how
they diagnose it now it's just becoming
a big problem because you get a label
and a prescription okay and then what is
the long-term effect do you eventually
come off this medication what are the
side effects when you come off is it
addictive these are all things that are
not worked out now living in an
environment with sensory overload you
know mainly this thing right here every
five seconds you're getting text
messages so our society is training us
to have less and less attention units
with all the different stimuli that are
around us so it's how do we get more
attention how do we get more done I want
to discuss that but let me first
Entertain You by going through how they
diagnose this it's completely
contrary it's there's no blood test it's
all subjective here we go the tension
deficit disorder hyperactivity disorder
there's two sections one for inattention
and the other is for hyperactivity I'm
going to go through both so if you have
six or more of these um you're diagnosed
often fails to give close attention to
detail or makes careless mistakes
okay I could think I have that uh B
often has difficulty sustaining
attention and task or playing activities
okay see often does not seem to listen
when spoken to directly all right next
one often does not follow through on
instructions and fails to finish
schoolwork tours duties in the workplace
which one of you have that one all right
next one often has difficulty organizing
tasks and activities now for me this is
why I hire people to do that part
because generally I am not very
organized all right next one often
avoids dislikes or is reluctant to
engage in tasks that require sustained
mental effort such as school work or
home work next one often loses things
necessary for tasks or activities toys
School assignments pencils books tools
you know your dog ate your homework
right which is a legitimate excuse all
right next one is often easily
distracted by extraneous
stimuli okay it's often forgetful in
daily activities I mean who does not
have virtually all of these now the next
one involves hyperactivity often fidgets
with hands or feet or squirms and seat I
do that all day long often leaves seat
in classroom or in other situations
often runs about or climbs successfully
in situations what if the person has a
lot of energy next one often has
difficulty playing or engaging in
leisure activities
quietly I guess if we play we need to be
quiet when we're playing I mean that is
ridiculous next one is often on the go
and often acts as if driven by a motor
wow that's interesting often talks
excessively so in other words we should
play quietly don't talk too much
don't seem to have too much energy make
sure you don't climb on anything now I
just have to just show you two of the
things that are um you know if you want
to be entertained today from this book
um page 736 it says adverse effects of
medication not otherwise specified and I
guess the code is 995.2 this category is
available for optional use by clinicians
to code side effects of medication when
these adverse effects become the main
focus of attention so if I understand
this correctly if the patient focuses
too much on the adverse effects then we
can throw this code in there now look at
this other one right here this diagnosis
is
v15-81 non-compliance with treatment
okay the reasons for non-compliance may
include discomfort resulting from
treatment you know like side effects
expense of treatment decisions based on
personal value judgments or religious or
cultural beliefs about the advantages
and disadvantages of proposed treatment
all right so whether you're diagnosed or
not and you want to increase your
attention your attention span realize
that add or ADHD has nothing to do with
someone's intelligence okay we're
talking about attention a lack of
attention and hyperactivity in some
cases intelligence is something
completely different there are people
are not intelligent that have this but
it's very difficult to even find the
definition of intelligence if you try to
look it up I guess the medical
professionals just don't agree on what
it is some people were related to the
grades you get in school or how well you
memorize things well to me that's not
necessarily intelligence I mean
intelligent people might be able to
memorize very well but people that can't
memorize are also in intelligent so I
think if we want to Define intelligence
we have to look at the opposite of
intelligence which is
stupidity okay what is that that's lack
of reasoning lack of knowledge
unawareness lack of judgment and so
intelligence must have logic rationality
reason the ability to think the ability
to solve problems and the ability to
quickly pick things up and understand
them but someone's learning ability can
also be affected by
just not having
um the right teacher that can teach you
the basics in school now I know for me
in school I had a really good teacher in
chemistry in high school that really
taught us the basics right so those
Basics allowed me to go to the next
level and learn more and more about
chemistry yet in other subjects I didn't
learn these Basics so it was very
difficult to learn things over this
Missing Foundation like right now I'm
studying genetics I'm interested in DNA
and a lot of the information the courses
assume you remember all the basics and I
literally had to find videos of teaching
genetics to kids to really wrap my wits
around these basic pieces and this
brings up a very important point if a
child is in school and they're not
really taught these Basics and they're
trying to learn high level things you
talk about confusion and a lack of
attention because you had no foundation
so everything is is a confusion so
unfortunately I think a lot of kids are
just diagnosed with this disorder when
in fact what they really need is better
study skills they need to learn how to
learn now there is a physical component
to this okay in your brain they don't
know this for sure but there's some
relationship between the frontal cortex
and your ability to concentrate
there's also a relationship between
another part of the brain called
hippocampus and your ability to focus
and concentrate which is in the category
of cognitive functions now what's
interesting about the brain is it's only
two percent of your body weight but
takes up 20 percent of your body's
energy and calories it's an energy hog
out of all the different organs it Hogs
the most energy and out of all the
organs it is the fattiest tissue sixty
percent of the brain is composed of fat
which is interesting now one important
thing you need to know about attention
okay is that it takes a lot of energy in
the brain to hold your attention because
it's not just holding your attention
it's filtering out distractions and
sensory stimulus things like that and so
if your brain is tired okay you're not
going to be able to filter out things as
much you're not going to be able to
concentrate for a long period of time so
I think a big part of this problem
relates to energy in the brain you've
probably been taught that the brain only
runs on glucose and this is the total
lie because you can run your body on
ketones in fact you can run your body on
75 ketones with only 25 percent
glucose and that 25 percent can come
from that protein or even ketones in
other words you don't need any
carbohydrates or glucose for that 25
energy so running your brain on ketones
can instantly give you a tremendous
amount of energy and on top of that
ketones are more efficient and the way
to feed your brain ketones is to just
lower your carbohydrates and then your
body will start oxidizing fat and then
from that you'll get ketones and ketones
release less waste in the brain so it's
a cleaner more efficient fuel source now
since we're on the topic of attention
and cognitive function we have to talk
about this I mean if you are consuming
gluten for example that's going to
affect the gut and that's going to
affect your brain you're not going to be
able to think you're going to be in a
constant state of brain fog like I was
for decades it wasn't until I gave up
the grains and went on the ketogenic
diet I felt like a helmet came off my
head I could finally Focus I can finally
think I could hold my attention so
getting rid of the grains on the diet is
going to be important and other things
that could be an allergy like casein you
can have an allergy that can also affect
the brain a lack of sleep is another big
factor too much caffeine can affect the
brain all of the nutrients okay there's
several nutrients that are vital for
brain energy and to counter this lack of
attention and the biggest one is vitamin
B1 if you don't have enough B1 okay you
are going to be in a constant state of
restlessness you're not going to have
this calmness you're going to have maybe
restless leg syndrome you're going to
have hyperactivity especially if you're
a child and you're definitely not going
to be able to think that well but it's
going to be mainly related to the
brain's energy so vitamin B1 is one of
the most important vitamins to counter
this attention deficit okay nutritional
yeast is a good source or find enough
actual B1 the next most important
nutrient is magnesium magnesium is
necessary to make energy in the brain or
ATP it's also necessary to calm the
brain if you have this hyperactivity and
you get magnesium from Leafy grains how
many kids consume enough vegetables well
it's very very few and far in between
but in one study over 58 percent of
children that had ADHD actually had a
magnesium deficiency which is quite
interesting because if you have a blood
deficiency of magnesium you are very
very deficient most of the Magnesium is
not in the blood it's inside the cell
and so it will show up as a deficiency
in the blood when the cell is severely
deficient and the next most important
nutrient deficiency to consider is
potassium if you were deficient in
potassium because of course you're not
consuming enough vegetables because
vegetables really give you potassium and
magnesium you're going to have a
difficult time filtering out sensory
information or sensory overload that is
going to greatly affect your ability to
hold your attention and then the other
one is omega-3 fatty acids omega-3 fatty
acids DHA EPA are essential for your
nerves to conduct electricity and
information so unfortunately too many
people including kids are consuming so
much omega-6 fatty acid soy corn canola
oil and not enough of the fish oils like
cod liver oil but that can make a big
difference when you start introducing
someone to cod liver oil or fish oils
they're not going to see a change
overnight you're going to have to do
this over a period of weeks to see the
change because it's a slow process now
there's another really really good
remedy I would recommend as a substitute
for Adderall or Ritalin now I'm not
telling you to come off your medication
I'm not telling you to substitute I just
want to give you this as a really good
solution to present with your doctor in
case you want to make make a switch it
has virtually no sound effects and it's
called
dmae okay this compound is actually in
sardines but I would recommend taking it
as a supplement it does several things
but it can help rid the brain waste that
can interfere with your focus it's very
neural protective okay so it's going to
help protect the brain against
inflammation and oxidative stress and
free radical damage but it increases the
receptor's ability to absorb
acetylcholine and that's the main
neurotransmitter that you need in these
Pathways it significantly and potently
increases focus and enhances
concentration so
dmae is what I would recommend as a
supplement of choice if you have ADD or
ADHD now you're probably also going to
notice you're going to sleep a little
bit better and your vision might be a
little bit better because it actually
gets rid of certain wastes that can
interfere with your retina which is an
extension of your brain okay number two
get on the ketogenic diet do
intermittent fasting if you haven't
already done that before and then B1
magnesium potassium okay and omega-3
fatty acids you can get your magnesium
and your potassium from leafy greens and
larger quantities and the next most
important video for you to watch would
be on how to get started
on the healthy version of the ketogenic
diet with intermittent fasting I put
that video up right here check it out